she got out of her car and was at the
window like trying to punch me
[Music]
hello my name is Fiona Mitchell and I am
a former Starbucks employee and my name
is Megan and I am a current Starbucks
employee hey I'm Rachel and I am a
former Starbucks barista and macey I'm
also a former Starbucks barista and
today we're playing the Starbucks
version of never have I ever
I have not never have I ever injured
myself at work I don't think so yeah
maybe like little burns and stuff I got
the first maybe like month I didn't have
non-slip shoes and I'm like I like
walking with hot ball flip this ball
cause it's easy coffee can spill the
beans can spill everything gets slippery
enhanced never have I ever had a
customer get mad at me because I didn't
make their drink right oh man if I had a
matter of days I had this one customer
he literally wanted everybody's life to
be miserable and he would come in there
to purposely make like okay let me see
if this person can make I've never seen
you here and then if you didn't do right
where does it matter but you did it
wrong it is just like dude like you take
like to think and I think people for the
most part we're nice but sometimes
really specific stuff like I want this
like 180 degrees it was tastes like 175
which is great if they do that though if
they're just like the drink tastes weird
I'm like where do we start how do I fix
any of that for you and it's just like
okay yes I'll just do it exactly the
same never have I ever been lectured by
a customer how they think the cup sizes
are annoying tall Grande and 50 oh yes I
am a cup the cup sizes
I couldn't even agree with you but like
why are we doing this but yes definitely
been lectured you do the fight over like
the headset whether you're there like
can I get a small latte and I'm like
awesome a tall latte they're like no no
no small and I'm like yeah I know no
swelling I'm taller the same thing
they're like well don't give me a big
one never have I ever had a customer
tell me a fake or insulting name to
write on their cup I've got enough they
it was like silly more than anything but
I don't think anything ever like
insulting I hate this because like I
feel kind of embarrassed when I have to
shout out to Big Daddy or something like
that and I'm just like big Big Daddy you
hear starting your latte man I could so
it's so awkward I've had some
experiences from kids see I play along
and like I'll have like a straight face
and they're like oh my god she's eating
it up and I'm like Seymour butts at
Seymour but I squat ain't never have I
ever been yelled at by a customer I had
a guy yell at me this morning I don't
think like yellow that I've gotten
yelled at a lot
I mean you lived in New York like if you
also think about it like they're coming
in to get their coffee people are
starting off their day sometimes people
just like their tolerance it's just low
just like I'm the first person you're
seeing in the morning yeah never have I
ever been asked to make a secret menu
item yeah no you have people coming up
to you and they assume that because you
are an employer okay hey like what's the
best break it was like well the Mickey's
right there know you got some special
stuff that I'm like I mean what do you
want me to make I was I was like a mix
of a regular mocha and a white mocha
yeah the black and white mocha clacking
way yeah yeah we also would make some
whipped cream that was like different
flavors but I like suing I could never
have I ever had a customer throw
something at me yeah I don't think so
me neither thank God wow that would that
was really suck so I'm gonna put they
attempted to throw a punch at me um she
like was driving through and I got this
drink and her card kept being declined
and I was like hey did you have another
card and she was like why would you
think my card was declined do you think
I can't I can't pay for the hand she
like pulls up her bank account and she's
like I have money how dare you she got
out of her car and was at the window
like trying to country it was one of
those things where I'm like
over coffee I had in older lady she had
to have been in her knees gave her her
the change bag and she was just like you
know what is this this is not you know
the actual change to act for him she was
like making a huge deal for no reason
and she basically took the change I mean
she threw it and like just spraining
money and coins and we're just like oh
never have I ever written a name wrong
on a cup on purpose and a lot of names
have like a lot of different ways to
spell them well if the name is wrong
like I'm just gonna call you Kay like
when you hear Kay like that yeah Oh like
that's yeah oh girl we got a nickname
because that's how close we are now
never have I ever been asked out on a
date by a customer I've also asked
customers out on date I was there for
six years over there through purity
there's just like it's just so
reoccurring and it just makes me laugh
of course I get this every time someone
orders a like tall blonde roast it's
always the tall blonde joke one one
person I did go on a date with and it
went terrible absolute like it you
couldn't imagine it going worse yeah so
that that's this thing don't
and then she happy girl just don't let
her go just don't don't date her it's
not gonna go you have to go to a
different coffee shop like just let it
go
you go to Starbucks every single day and
I don't really think anymore about like
oh when I was doing that thing but
reading some of these like have you ever
like purposely made the wrong drink or
purposely wrote a name or like no one's
doing that like everyone just trying
their best
so cut people some slack and like be
nice to people that work at Starbucks
cuz they're nice people yeah
[Music]